when it comes to
i feel like there's no shortcut to
getting
the type of following you have because
you have fans who
like are fully engaged in your life and
they're fully invested in you as like a
person so if you drop a t-shirt or you
put out a new record or whatever like
they're there you go on tour
like a lot of people who have way more
followers than you can't tour like you
yeah why give a [ __ ] you know what i
mean i think that's the biggest thing is
like
i actually care about these human beings
like there's been times when i can put
up the ticket price or i can
you know i've had these conversations
with like industry people like well why
don't you just do this or charge more
for this or whatever and i'm like bro
you got to know what type of fans i have
like i have fans that
you know single moms or kids you know
that come from
parent you know their parents are
immigrants or whatever like you can't
just be like oh
bet pay 150 now for my ticket just
because i want to just because you want
to hit a lick yeah like no that's not
that's [ __ ] scummy and i think that's
one thing that goes a long way for
people
you know and and there's both type of
artists you could be that you can be all
about the clout and you can
be poppin and that's cool if that's what
you want with your life
not knocking you at all me personally i
don't feel good about that and i
can't live a life where i just like feel
shitty about myself
also you like physically see your fans
like you'll go you're like you got to
see these people on tour
yeah i'm on stage and i'm like staring
at them and i'm like damn i feel bad
like no like but there is scummy people
in this industry sure that's why there's
[ __ ] that gotta be high they
gotta stay high like you done did so
much scummy [ __ ] in your life
you gotta stay high and [ __ ] be able
to live with yourself and it's like god
damn